Is the King of the Monsters also the king of
the box office? 4 billion dollars for Lucasfilm;
was it worth it? Was Wolverine strong enough
to support the entire X-Men movie franchise
on his furry back? These movies brought back
long dormant franchises to a planet near you.
"Star Trek" is one of the most influential
and long-running media franchises of all time.
It's easy to forget that the original "Star Trek"
television series was unceremoniously canceled
after its third season in 1969. "Star
Trek" gained cultural momentum in reruns
during the 1970s, though, leading to a
brief revival as an animated series and
a planned return to live-action
television called "Star Trek:
Phase II." After the box success of "Star Wars"
in 1977, Paramount changed course and relaunched
"Star Trek" on the big screen, resulting
in 1979's "Star Trek: The Motion Picture."
"The Motion Picture" was a financial success but a
critical failure whose plodding pace earned it the
fan nickname "The Slow-Motion Picture." Paramount
was willing to try making another "Star Trek"
film, but only if it could be done on a much
smaller budget. But despite being made on the
cheap by unproven director Nicholas Meyer, "Star
Trek II: The Wrath of Khan" made an immediate
cultural impact, becoming a legitimate mainstream
hit and winning back eight times its budget.
"The Wrath of Khan" launched a new,
prosperous era in which "Star Trek"
thrived both on the big screen and back
on television for another two decades.
"KHAAAAAAAN!"
Following the success of "Wrath
of Khan," "Star Trek" became a
pop culture brand that was
everywhere, spanning movies,
television, and beyond. The original cast
continued to star in feature films throughout
the '80s before hanging it up in "Star
Trek VI: The Undiscovered Country" in 1991.
Meanwhile, "Trek" was undergoing a renaissance
on television, with a string of TV spin-offs
that ran for 18 consecutive years and
a cumulative 624 episodes. "Star Trek:
The Next Generation" was a big enough hit to
warrant its own leap to the big screen, which kept
the film series alive until the critical and box
office failure of "Star Trek: Nemesis" in 2002.
When "Trek's" television run likewise came to
an end with the cancellation of "Star Trek:
Enterprise" in 2005, the franchise went into
stasis for the first time since the mid-1970s.
Paramount wouldn't let "Trek" rest for too long.
In 2007, J.J. Abrams was officially attached to
direct a new part-sequel, part-prequel,
part-reboot simply titled "Star Trek."
This radical reimagining of the original
source material reignited mainstream
interest in the franchise, making it one
of the highest-grossing films of 2009.
Since then, "Trek" has had two more feature
film sequels and yet another television revival,
with producer Alex Kurtzman now at the helm
of the franchise's five new streaming series.
Beginning with its first installment in 2000,
the "X-Men" franchise was at the forefront of
the superhero movie boom. Each chapter of the
original "X-Men" trilogy outgrossed the last,
raking in a cumulative billion dollars
in worldwide box office receipts.
With the original cast's story concluded,
20th Century Fox sought to expand the
franchise with a variety of new spin-offs,
beginning with "X-Men Origins: Wolverine"
in 2009. "Wolverine" introduced the characters
of Gambit and Deadpool to the big screen,
and they were each eyed for their own spin-offs.
Additionally, two more prequels were planned,
one centered around Magneto and another on
Charles Xavier's original class of X-Men.
But after the messy release and critical failure
of "X-Men Origins: Wolverine," 20th Century Fox
put the rest of their "X-Men" slate on hold,
focusing instead on a single project: the prequel
film "X-Men: First Class," which featured
an entirely new cast and a period setting.
"First Class" didn't immediately reverse the
franchise's box office fortunes, earning about
$10 million less than "X-Men Origins: Wolverine"
on a similar budget, but it was better received
by fans and critics, putting the franchise back
in the right direction. Its immediate sequel,
"X-Men: Days of Future Past," combined the
new and original X-Men film casts and became
a massive box office hit. Incidentally, "Days
of Future Past" also erased the poorly received
"Last Stand" and "Origins" from continuity
by way of time travel. Neat trick, huh?
1968's "Planet of the Apes" is one of the sci-fi
genre's best films, as well as the launchpad of
its first long-running sci-fi film franchises.
The original "Planet of the Apes" spawned four
direct sequels in rapid succession between 1970
and 1973. And when the series fizzled out on film,
the franchise moved to television — first as a
live-action series, then in animation — but both
efforts were short-lived. With
the cartoon's cancelation in 1975,
"Planet of the Apes" disappeared from both
film and television for a quarter-century.
A big-budget, Tim Burton-helmed reimagining
of "Planet of the Apes" was released in 2001,
which turned a profit but was such a critical
disaster that the franchise was immediately put
back on the shelf. The next reboot attempt came
a decade later with 2011's prequel "Rise of the
Planet of the Apes." It gave new life to the
franchise, replacing the previous generations'
make-up effects with remarkably expressive CGI
apes performed via motion capture by the likes
of Andy Serkis. "Rise" spawned a successful
new "Apes" trilogy whose middle chapter,
"Dawn of the Planet of the Apes," was a
critical darling as well as a smash hit.
Unsurprisingly, another reboot of the
franchise is already in the works.
"Get your stinking paws off
me, you damn dirty ape!”
Ridley Scott's 1979 sci-fi/horror mashup
"Alien" is a classic in both genres,
so it's remarkable that anyone was able to
create even one sequel of comparable quality
in the first place. James Cameron's
1986 follow-up "Aliens" triumphed by
continuing the journey of original
film protagonist Ellen Ripley with
a totally different approach and tone,
but this trick proved difficult to repeat.
1992's "Alien 3" distanced itself from the
action-oriented tone of "Aliens" and was
poorly received, while 1997's "Alien:
Resurrection" seemed to overcorrect,
becoming a bizarre comic book-y affair that
grossed poorly in North America. The brand
was kept alive for a time by crossing over with
the similarly struggling "Predator" franchise,
but the "Alien vs. Predator" film series
likewise fell apart after two entries.
It would take Ridley Scott himself to lend
credibility back to the universe that he
helped create. His 2012 film "Prometheus" is
set in the same universe as "Alien," but follows
another set of characters on a journey that's
only tangentially connected to the events of
the original film. More importantly, it shares
"Alien's" moody, unsettling tone and gruesome
body horror, and added even loftier
philosophical and ontological themes.
While reviews were mixed, "Prometheus" became
the highest-grossing film in the franchise,
leading to sequel "Alien: Covenant,"
which also serves as a more direct
prequel to the original film. With
interest in "Alien" fully revitalized,
an additional film and a spin-off
television series are forthcoming.
Godzilla is one of cinema's most prolific
and iconic monsters, having starred in 36
films since 1954. His longevity as a movie icon
has been assured by his occasionally going into
hibernation, as he did in 1975, 1995, and finally
in 2004. On the occasion of the original film's
50th anniversary, Japanese studio Toho released
"Godzilla: Final Wars," which brought an
end to the "Millennium era" of Godzilla movies and
put the famous kaiju to rest for the third time.
A decade later, Gareth Edwards' 2014 American
"Godzilla" was a critical and box office success.
Not only did the 2014 "Godzilla" lead to the
expansion of Legendary's "Monsterverse," (crossing
Godzilla over with King Kong for the first time
in half a century), but also prompted Toho to
revive Godzilla in Japan. "Godzilla Resurgence"
was not only a hit at the Japanese box office
in 2016 but also the recipient of the Japan
Academy Film Prize for Picture of the Year.
The original 1979 "Mad Max" is a small
miracle of filmmaking. The debut feature
from writer/director George Miller was produced
for less than half a million dollars and became
such a hit that it held the world record for the
most profitable film in terms of cost vs. gross,
until it was toppled by "The Blair Witch
Project" in 1999. Its two sequels, "Mad Max
2" (aka "The Road Warrior") and "Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome" were increasingly expensive and
outlandish, but also won increasing financial
returns. "Beyond Thunderdome" was a hit,
but was considered a slight step down
in quality from its predecessors.
After directing three "Mad Max" films
in six years, Miller was certain that
he was finished with the series in 1985. But
inspiration for "Fury Road" struck hard in 1998,
leading to a torturously long development
process. The film was almost made in 2003,
then again in 2010, before cameras finally
began rolling in 2012. By the time "Mad Max:
Fury Road" hit theaters in 2015, the
series had been dormant for 30 years.
The wait was worth it — "Fury Road" was an
unqualified critical and commercial success that
earned 10 Academy Award nominations, including
Best Picture. Audiences clamored for more,
and a franchise was reborn. Two more "Mad Max"
films are currently in development, one featuring
series lead Max and one expanding on the origins
of the breakout character of “Fury Road”- Furiosa.
There should probably never have been a sequel
to "Jurassic Park" in the first place — the
moral of the original film is that a theme park
full of sharp-toothed, ravenous, prehistoric
monsters is a bad idea that should never be tried
again. But try they have, over and over again.
After the 1993 original came the underwhelming
1997 sequel "The Lost World: Jurassic Park."
If Steven Spielberg himself couldn't make
a successful sequel to his own classic,
what hope could anyone else have? 2001's
"Jurassic Park III" was even less successful,
but plans for a "Jurassic Park IV"
continued to roll on nevertheless
with a decade-long marathon of rejected scripts.
Finally, in 2015, Universal and director Colin
Trevorrow released their long-awaited, big-budget
attempt to clone their cash cow, "Jurassic World."
Sporting an entirely new set of characters but
deeply rooted in nostalgia for the original,
"Jurassic World" was a colossal box office hit,
raking in over $1.6 billion worldwide and
spawning a pair of sequels of its own.
Like their genetically reconstituted stars, the
"Jurassic World" films really shouldn't exist,
but there's no denying that the
franchise is alive and well.
From the moment Disney purchased
Lucasfilm for $4 billion in 2012,
it was a sure thing that "Star Wars"
would be coming back to the big screen,
and nearly as certain that their first
movie out of the gate would be a smash hit.
Just as in the case of 1999's "The Phantom
Menace," anticipation and speculation alone
would have brought filmgoers out in droves to
see if the old "Star Wars" magic had come back,
no matter how disappointed they may have been in
George Lucas' prequel trilogy a decade earlier.
What's remarkable about "Star Wars: Episode VII —
The Force Awakens," though, is the sheer magnitude
of its success. It grossed over $936 million in
the U.S. alone and over $2 billion worldwide. It
also got the warmest reception from critics of any
"Star Wars" film since "The Empire Strikes Back."
Fans may have mixed feelings as to the overall
quality of the post-buyout "Star Wars" brand,
but "The Force Awakens" announced loud and
clear that "Star Wars" was back in a big way.
It's unlikely to be retired again any time soon.
The Marvel Cinematic Universe, the most
financially successful film franchise of all time,
is essentially one big franchise made of many
smaller ones. Almost every one of the 23 films
in its ambitious "Infinity Saga" won its opening
weekend, turned a profit, and spawned a sequel.
Sure, all the movies were hits, but
answer us this question — after "Thor:
The Dark World," was anybody out there
really clamoring for more solo Thor movies?
"The Dark World" has the lowest Rotten Tomatoes
score in the "Infinity Saga," and the first "Thor"
doesn't score much higher. With Chris Hemsworth's
original Marvel contract expiring with "Avengers:
Endgame," who's to say there'd have been enough
heat behind the character to renew any further?
Director Taika Waititi, that's who! Waititi
took this ailing corner of the MCU for a hard
left turn with "Thor: Ragnarok," giving
it a new sense of humor and a new cast
of supporting characters. "Ragnarok" outgrossed
"The Dark World" globally by over $200 million,
and rests near the top of many lists ranking the
MCU's best films. Its success prompted rewrites of
"Avengers: Infinity War," and the more comedic
version of the character is set to return for
another "Thor" film with Waititi at the helm.
Hemsworth hopes to continue to play Thor for
years to come, something that almost certainly
wouldn't have happened if not for "Ragnarok."
"I thought you were gone forever!
I'm glad to see you back!"
"You're ruining my disguise!"
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite sci-fi franchises are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.